Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man over wings.
Liberty is such a wandering thing, behind us all, come see, come take your place, we're
leaving soon for-
She's to say, for services above and beyond the call of duty performed by risk of life
and limb, I wish to award the order of merit with highest honors.
Not at all, not at all.
Any humanoid would have done the same thing.
And of course, in honoring Metro, we can only reflect glory on his creator,
our universally renowned, inimitable Professor Maestro,
the most brilliant mind in all our confederation.
What's he got to do with this anyway? He didn't do anything. He's a big thinker.
And now, let us lift our glasses to our newly promoted Captain Pirro,
who has earned this promotion through his exceptional courage and intelligence.
Thank you, Captain Pirro.
Youngest officer ever to hold such a high rank in the confederation. We're proud of you.
As for Lieutenant Pettigrew, our own slugger,
Your new insignia of full lieutenant bears witness to your devotion to duty,
to your courage, which you have demonstrated in every performance of duty.
We are proud of you, lieutenant.
I'm sure the great of captain isn't far away.
I have reserved for the last honors,
Lieutenant Mercedes, affectionately known to us all as Psyche,
by using her absolutely extraordinary powers,
which have so often transformed certain defeat into brilliant victory.
She has shown coolness and courage in the face of danger.
Her youth and apparent fragility disguise an indomitable will.
May you go on to serve as an example to other young women.
You may be sure that a brilliant career lies ahead of you.
Who can say how grateful our confederation may be one day?
All our very best wishes to you, Psyche, and our hope for your continued success.
Looking at her.
Oh, awesome, Psyche.
Yeah, sure right.
Hooray!
Apologies, sir. Urgent message from Leto.
Just a moment, please.
That's enough solemn ceremony.
Now our youngsters have earned a good time.
It's time for music with the Omega Group.
We did it, didn't we?
We? What do you mean, we?
We's right behind you.
Yes, that is a good place for you.
Just make sure that you're far enough back so that you don't get in my way.
And the colonel's waiting for you.
Excuse me.
The youngsters have earned a rest, some relaxation.
They've been in strenuous action for many months now.
After all, we have several other crews who are competent.
But they were requested.
They expressly said that's the crew, including Metro, that they wanted.
Very strange.
Yes. Well, they form a united team.
Why don't we ask them what they think? They're concerned?
You recall your adventures on the planet Leto?
I beat Golden Bar.
It appears new trouble's broken out. It's all very strange.
As I understand it, this time it's the men who have revolted.
At least that's what I gather from their message.
There's been a kind of ceasefire between men and robots awaiting your arrival.
But what makes the whole situation peculiar is they're expressly requesting that we send one certain individual, Metro.
But why him?
Oh, I don't see anything so unusual in that. I taught them a good lesson.
Anyway, the three of you form a team.
You know, you don't have to go if you don't want to. You're technically on leave.
Oh, you needn't trouble these two. I'll go alone.
Now you think you can pilot a spaceship?
Now all that is just routine, an hour or two, and I know I'll be ready to handle any ship.
I think it'll be all right, Madame President. You agree, Piero?
We had a good rest on Earth.
I feel great.
And we always work best as a team, right?
Here we are again, the three of us, just like the good old days.
You know, it's a little sad to think it's one of our last missions in this ship.
Our good old hummingbird.
Pretty soon, Captain, you'll be commanding a cruiser.
And when that happens, Lieutenant,
all that will remain is to select a second in command.
I guess you'll do.
And I will go on just checking circuits.
Ho-hum.
An android decorated with the Order of Merit is meant for higher things.
Quite right.
Metro, you will be up here in a command post.
And that means you'll be able to get us out of trouble more and more.
And for openers, it looks like you're going to run the show in this operation.
Kind of funny they ask for you, isn't it?
I don't think it's so strange.
I would just remind you I was rather impressive against their golden bar.
I think these ambulating junkyards would agree.
Planet Leto approaching.
And they did all they could to assist your landing.
Well, I don't understand it at all.
I wouldn't have expected it.
Ah, I think they were delighted to see us again.
They were delighted to see Metro again.
couldn't take their eyes off him it's true your exploits are known everywhere you're a star around
here metro can we get back to the situation governor what's wrong and why this revolt since
your departure the robot scene has been exemplary they've respected the treaty scrupulously in fact
they went overboard couldn't do enough for us very kind gentle even friendly as if they wanted
to shield us from any unpleasantness any effort at first we liked it everything for us on
construction sites and they worked at least as well as we could in the end it was boring however
every time we tried to complain they'd give us yet another toy. We began to wonder if they weren't
trying to sap our energy. What really shattered us was the boredom. Still, you went along with it.
No complaints were received on Omega. Yes, it's true. And even now I wonder where we found the
energy to stage any kind of revolt at all. Where did it start? We have a certain place just outside
the city. Well, in old ruins, neoclassical architecture, Doric. We call it our Acropolis.
I suppose we don't have many people here who know why it's called that. It's always been a symbol for
A tradition of liberty and democracy.
Man, the measure of all things.
A kind of myth, I suppose.
Families would go there on holidays.
Of course it was in ruins.
But when Robot Supreme decided to level it,
to put up some new project,
though it was useless, we fought them
with whatever few arms we still had.
It was suicide. They outnumbered us ten to one.
They went on being nice to us.
They refused combat, refused to annihilate us,
as they discreetly put it.
They said, "We are not your enemies."
Arbitrator, that's why you are here.
Supreme Liouzine is here for the delegation from Omega.
We're VIPs now, Metro, how's that?
No, it's no more than we deserve.
...of a robot, his nobility.
We'll begin in a few moments.
Welcome to Tenant.
Polite Ladner.
And what is your side, Colonel?
...creatures, we can find no other conclusion.
I will explain.
Create robots to serve you efficiently and well.
Then, when we carry out our tasks too well, you complain.
Only one conclusion.
We robots are rational, men are not.
They're all individuals. Unique. They're not machines. With them, it's judgment. Selection, proportion. You can't do that.
Changeable. What is most elusive is what interests him most.
Colonel, truer words were never spoken. Only why not let them choose what's good for them?
He is unable to maintain any choice.
Shouldn't he be allowed to change his mind?
We never change our minds. It is why we are superior.
Man has a sense of pleasure and displeasure.
But since these complex motivations are not integrated into your circuits, you cannot comprehend. You feel superior.
For you, we are no more than objects. Is that not right?
But the life we embody is as real to us as yours is to you.
And experience has proven that we are stronger, more competent, wiser than you are. In short, superior.
It's beginning to get on my nerves, this Colonel.
Why, you're no more than a tangled mass of wires, copper tubing, printed circuits, and plastic wrapped up in a metal shell.
You will allow me to remind you, sir, that you are made of the same, but since you insist on identifying yourself with your makers, I would point out that they are no different in theory.
They use slightly different materials, bits of carbon compounds, traces of metals, all inside a soft skin, so much for man.
Colonel, I find this discussion rather academic. Is it for this we were asked to come?
In our view, the old ruins called Acropolis are taking up space and serve no purpose.
We have decided to construct on the site an example of tomorrow's reality.
What reality? What terribly sad reality?
Listen once and for all.
Men are ready to fight for their ideals and traditions, and so are we.
What do you suggest?
Perhaps you recall your last visit to our planet.
To avoid decimating both sides, you suggested a single combat, chief to chief.
At present, we do not have weapons.
We know that we, the robots, are the stronger, but we do not wish to harm you.
we challenge you here and now will you accept such a fight champion against champion a fight
to the finish yes and then what the winner will dictate conditions but the fight will be divided
into two stages and to be declared winner he must win both stages not necessarily against the same
opponent if the first is unable to continue but then it's really two fights and i shall have to
fight both of them exactly don't you know our entire planet sings your praises knows how you
You felled our golden bar, the Invincible.
Now you will furnish us the opportunity to settle the score.
But I wouldn't call that fair.
Colonel, exactly why do you want this fight?
Let us say to prove our superiority.
Why, aren't you too sure?
Doubt is an emotion.
We do not possess emotions.
We consider demonstrated proof a more reliable guide to understanding.
One question, Colonel.
What are we waiting for?
Not awfully polite of your champion to keep me waiting.
Terribly sorry, sir.
But all things come to him who waits.
Here he is.
Our Battle Chieftain General Goldenbar II.
The delegation from Omega, I presume.
And this bit of tinsel, can this be the one I heard so much about?
Well, modestly, I might say, yes, it's me. How do you do?
How do you do? Now, I don't want there to be any disagreeable surprises.
Since our last meeting, there have been a few improvements on my side.
Our new beryllium-iridium alloy can attain a fusion temperature of 6,000 degrees.
Also, we are equipped with an ingenious built-in self-repair capability,
which instantly manufactures and attaches any elements that it may be damaged.
And would you believe we can reproduce ourselves at will whenever we deem it necessary.
Okay, fellas, back.
Now, what do you say to that mousetrap?
Very good, very good.
But it doesn't go very far, you know, not at all.
Now, tell the truth.
What else can you do?
Well, now that you ask, I have a brand new anti-gravity thing.
I can sort of fly.
Watch, I'll show you.
There you are.
An android forewarned is forearmed, they say.
But forearmed or backarmed, you're going to come to harm in the end, my own proverb.
What about your improvements? Are you too shy?
Eh, what's the use? You, Goldenboro, are obviously the greatest, the handsomest, the strongest, the cleverest.
Gentlemen, may the combat commence.
Hey, Goldie, if you'd rather be on this side, I don't mind.
Right, you say you're so crammed full of gadgets? Let's see what you can do, Goldie.
Guess who? I need new glasses. I'm seeing three.
Metro, squire, tell me you turn out quite a few like this.
Is this him? This spec? I didn't see this little thing.
Thing yourself, you bullying tower.
This second stage of combat, in order to keep the fight fair, we shall reveal the special capacities of the general.
Possesses no anti-gravity system. He does not fly.
Luckily, he possesses no regeneration capability.
No, the only faculty he does possess is one of reproducing himself.
But we don't consider that fair.
And he can duplicate himself all he wants?
No, he cannot. He is limited in his capacity.
So far, he can reproduce four alter egos in all.
But we are perfecting a new model much improved.
So, all together, I'll have to fight five of these guys.
It's not right. That's five against one.
It is possible for you to renounce combat at any time
and thus spare yourself any damage. You have only to ask.
That is something I wouldn't count on if I were you.
Don't you worry. I will be all right, I guarantee it.
However, as for all of those overgrown tin cans,
They are going to need quite a few space trains to carry away all the piles of junk that I am going to turn them into, and the sooner.
We're with you, Metro. Watch yourself. Don't get hurt.
When you've finished your little chat, maybe we can begin.
Gentlemen, are you ready? Let the combat commence.
Hey, you don't think you're going to get away with that again, do you?
Do just a little better than that.
Do a little better, don't you worry. How is this, for starters?
Anybody for a game of tennis?
we've won the first round gonna join the party the more the mere selves i'm having a ball no need to
turn yourself into a ball again all maneuvers so far in combat have been stored in our memory bank
and reprogrammed in our computer with correct counteraction well well well aren't you clever
now for something new enough now we advance and finish combat seize crush destroy good well at
least now i'll know what to expect just one moment please just one moment have you ever heard the
story of the Pied Piper of Hamlin. Our circuits are not equipped for fanciful stories. Response
negative. Got something to learn, all right. A little mythology, as it were. Not a bad
idea. Follow me. Where are you going? You stay, we fight. This is a regular. Trap. I've seen
this done many times. Well, it always works in the Western movies. I can go. It's your
chance. Planking about. Excellent lesson. Colonel, I still don't understand. Exactly
why are we here? Why did you ask us to come? Lieutenant, I thought it was obvious. So you
would teach us show us where there are still gaps in our understanding and capacities to correct
this event is a victory for you yes we see it it is merely another stage in our development defeat
is unimportant all that is important is final victory for us and we have no doubt whatever
that in the end we will win leap journey home tenant victorious hero so wondrous your place